Lucy uh lovely to talk to you today
known also as the writer on one half of
meets the Richardsons as well and just
lovely to see you and speak to you what
are your feelings about the mini budget
what happened that happened on Friday
and the impact that it's potentially
going to have
I mean
is that I'm fine but they haven't been
fine since the introduction of the
bedroom tax
had a massive effect on people that it
totally destabilized things and then
it's built and built and I'm worried
about them I'm worried about how they
feel I'm worried about their the impact
of them to be able to parent it's
massive because this is our next
Generation the stresses put on a on a
parent's brain when they are working in
a low income family people are still
reeling and you know we just had last
week
um about the the changes to Universal
Credit about how many hours you can be
you can't just slash that you know I
work with families that are from you
know that they're from under supported
areas and they have a complex needs and
from complex areas you you can't just
slash something like that these are you
know work with a lot of families where
they can't work any more hours because
you know they might be grandparents and
they're having to spawn as part of the
grandchildren or you know the the
disabled there is only so many hours
they can do and you can't just slash it
it has to be baby steps you know and um
it's just there is almost too much to
take on
um at once but I'm incredibly worried
about as I said the ability to parent
um a child you know we are talking about
this what what we've seen since covid
and to now we're seeing families that
are going through acute trauma that are
bringing children up in a household that
are suffering trauma that will have
developmental effects for the next 20
years because because they're not
supported in the right way and it feels
like
um the government have this ideal family
unit the picture what what a modern
British family looks like but it but
it's not true people have complex needs
and we know poverty affects everything
you know you you hear police chief um
police chief you know police saying
crime is because of poverty
um you know we
we can't live in a country where it's
okay to be privately wealthy and and and
and publicly and in a mess we need to
live you know yeah what what would you
like to see the government doing to help
the kind of families that you work with
and see struggling
the help was there the help was there
um in the Blair government the first
things he did was he with Hull
personally and you know which where my
family are from the first thing Blair
did I mean obviously you know further
down the line there was issues and he
became very unpopular but
um a centuries labor government you know
the the first thing he did was um he he
helped fishermen's families his best um
like a couple of hours on the job he
made sure that they were supported
because the industry had just been left
to ruin and and one of the biggest
things he did was the shore start
centers
um you know he said education education
education I had like
you know labor have to say early
intervention early intervention and it's
something that Tory government know
nothing about they do not seem to
understand how to help complex
under-supported families and it's all
down to early intervention and it saves
money in in the public sector in the
long run you know the amount of children
going into Care at the moment is is
unsustainable when we know that it costs
upwards of three thousand pounds a week
to have a child in care and but if if
there's early intervention so I would
have I like them to to be looking at the
most vulnerable first I just wish the
government was a good parent if it looks
Through The Eyes of a child because
children have a set of
um International children's rights all
of their own and I really feel if we
look at a vulnerable child take take a
child in Middlesbrough Liverpool you
know Blackpool what does that child need
and we build policies around it it will
help everybody and and that's what I'm
not seeing I'm not seeing them
understanding the importance of early
intervention and this is going to have
an effect on us for years you know we
know so much more now about
neurodevelopment than we ever did we
have to start
healing I know you know it might sound
quite work but we need to heal a lot
there's a lot that's gone on and
children should be at the center of
everything especially the vulnerable
ones
really interested to talk to you today
Lucy Beaumont anti-poverty campaign and
comedian thank you very much thank you